- [Voiceover] So, we want to evaluate the
definite integral from
negative one to eight
of 12 times the cube root of x dx.
Let's see, this is going
to be the same thing
as the definite integral from negative one
to eight of 12 times, the cube root is
the same thing as saying
x to the 1/3 power dx
and so now, if we want to
take the antiderivative
of the stuff on the inside,
we're just going to do
essentially the power rule,
it conduces the power rule of integrals
or it's the reverse of the
power rule for derivatives,
where we increase this exponent by one
and then we divide by
that increased exponent.
So, this is going to
be equal to 12 times x
to the 1/3 plus one.
Let me do that in another color,
so we can keep track of it.
X to the 1/3 plus one and
then we're going to divide
by 1/3 plus one and so,
what's 1/3 plus one,
well, that's 4/3, 1/3
plus 3/3, that's 4/3.
So, I could write it this way.
I could write this x to the 4/3 divided by
4/3 and this is going to be
and I'm going to evaluate
this at the bounds.
So, I'm going to evaluate this at
and I'll do this in different colors,
I'm going to evaluate it at eight
and I'm going to evaluate
it at negative one
and I'm going to subtract
it and evaluate it
at negative one from this
expression evaluated at eight,
and so what is this going to be equal to?
Well, actually, let me
simplify a little bit more.
What is 12 divided by 4/3?
So, 12, I'll do it right, well, I'll
do it right over here,
12 over 4/3 is equal to 12 times 3/4,
which will give you as 12/1 times 3/4,
12 divided by four is three,
so this is going to be equal to nine,
3/4 of 12 is nine.
So, this, we could rewrite this,
we could write this as
nine x to the 4/3 power.
So, if we evaluate it at eight,
this is going to be nine times eight
to the 4/3 power and from that,
we're going to subtract and
evaluate it at negative one.
So, this is going to be
nine times negative one
to the 4/3 power.
So, what is eight to the 4/3 power?
I'll do it over here.
So, eight to the 4/3 is equal to eight
to the 1/3 to the fourth power,
these are just exponent properties here.
Eight to the 1/3, the cube root of eight,
or eight to the 1/3 power, that's two,
'cause two to the third power is eight
and two to the fourth power,
well two to the fourth
power is equal to 16.
So, eight to the 4/3 is 16
and what's a negative one
to the 4/3?
Well, same idea, negative one to the 4/3
is equal to negative one, there's several
way you could do it.
You could say negative one to the fourth
and the cube root of that,
or the cube root of negative one
and then raise that to the
fourth power, either way.
So, let's do it the first way.
Negative one to the fourth and then
take the cube root of that.
Well, negative one to
the fourth is just one
and then one to the 1/3 power,
well that's just going to be equal to one.
So, what we have here in blue,
that's just equal to one.
So, we have nine times
16 minus nine time one,
well, that's just going
to be nine times 15.
We have 16/9 and then we're
going take away a nine,
so that's going to be nine times 15,
so what is that?
That is going to be equal to nine times 15
is 90 plus 45, which is equal to 135,
135 and we're done.